[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record we talk about
whatever we want
[Music]
[Applause]
timmy why are you wearing this shirt
what's going on big a
oh dude you know what here's what i've
been doing like like through the whole
quarantine right i'll be up at like 2 3
a.m
[ __ ] on zillow looking up how much
houses cost and like oshkosh wisconsin
and [ __ ] just cuz
in weird places i've been doing [ __ ]
like that too wait in random just weird
places yeah random places to see how
much they cost and what they look like
but also i'll randomly be like man
i wonder if they have t-shirts for like
big age go online
and i'll look and then i'll i'll find
one i'm like oh it's sweet i ordered it
and i just ordered like random shirts
wait who's big head oh 90 day fiance
that's right yeah okay that's right you
know you know rose
yeah she follows brie really yes
and i told brielle's like get her on but
she's in the philippines ah
yeah so they didn't make it yeah
so it's like you know because like this
whole like genre of shirt like they're
like the band shirts it's just like it's
like
it's like a thing so you can damn near
find a banter for anybody nowadays it's
not like that like really stiff
like yeah weird ass they're supposed to
like feel like it's like old you know
what i'm saying yeah
you could have convinced me that he was
a 90s wwf guy yeah yeah
yeah bro mayo what
it says mayo makes my hair
shine because he can you imagine if
that's your brand
you're like hey i'm the mayo makes my
hair shine guy oh my god
he uses mayo yeah you never saw that
episode he was getting ready for rose
and he was like yeah you know
like i conditioned my hair with
mayonnaise and you know people say it's
weird but like it gets it very silky
but what does it smell like dude mayo by
the way wait he leaves it's the
vegetable oil that's what it is
i'm sure i'm sure he washes it out okay
because if he washes it then i'm like
okay i could see that i could see that
as like a hair
treatment yeah i just can't respect it
though yeah no i guess not
let's not respect that i mean it's yeah
it's just like corn oil or something let
me ask you guys something do you guys
like mayonnaise yes
i love it depends i go back and forth
loving it but okay
i love mayonnaise but i'm not like a
over saucer drencher guy
like i like i like it i like it you mix
it or you bite it yeah i do that myself
when i first
discovered had uh when i first
discovered how to make a sandwich right
mayonnaise was a game changer because my
grandma's like you didn't even use the
mayonnaise and i was like what is that
and she goes that's this bottle and it
was like a best foods one
i picture like a light shining on it
you know the blue label and [ __ ] and
then like
um she's like yeah you got to put a
layer of this and i was like oh my god
this is why
sandwiches are so good yeah bro i uh i
need mayo on my sandwiches i dip i did
fries and mayonnaise oh you do
yeah very european of you yeah i learned
that when i was
in like in in uh in europe but i just i
feel like there's
a lot of people that don't like
mayonnaise i don't like a lot
nikki hates mayonnaise really she hates
it it's disgusting to her but i think
you can't have the blt without
mayonnaise that's what it is
blt's it's too dry you've seen it a
little bit a little bit i used to hate
mustard when i was younger i'm like oh
it's so like
like the real [ __ ] or the yellow [ __ ] i
don't know what's the real
one with the seeds in it looks all tan
looking look at that still don't like
that till this day
brown mustard i used to hate mustard too
but now it's like all the condiments man
throw them on yeah i love that
that's how i knew i was an adult when i
liked mustard yeah because i used to eat
pickles too that was like it's just too
strong of a flavor my like taste buds
were like i couldn't handle it i used to
hate ketchup
but i loved mustard so i always have hot
dogs with just mustard and i'm digging
you are one of those kids yeah because i
always wondered why
it's because i don't like the sweet part
i just want the spicy original way to
eat sausages
is mustard mustard only are you one of
those guys now
are you gonna uh if you eat ketchup on a
hot dog you're like
anti i don't take it that seriously now
you know when you're a kid
and you have your identity and you're
like i have to protect this at all costs
i'm a mustard kind of guy yeah i only
like mustard actually okay grandma
but now it's just like yeah it's fine
bro david david [ __ ] loves ketchup i
didn't know this about him he does
we're shooting an episode of send food a
poser i'm like yo would you like
would you like some ketchup and i
squirted he's like oh dude i actually
love ketchup and i was like really
i squirted a bunch and then i thought he
was joking about how much he loves
ketchup but their points he's like oh no
i could just eat it took a scoop i was
like
i was like bruh i'm like i'm shocked and
like i'm really
kind of like grossed out by you right
now like i've never filmed this so like
or at least the three that we're talking
about mayo mustard and ketchup i could
do a spoonful of ketchup
if i had to well yeah no because he used
to make fun of me how much ketchup i use
right so i'm like
this [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] that you eat on your show
and [ __ ] you're gonna clown on him for
eating a spoonful of ketchup
no anything let's do it poultry school i
would just get ketchup packets and eat
them
interesting you're one of those oh
there's a sadder reason but i'm not
going to say it you're hungry yes
oh [ __ ] that was a sad reason
i used to do that too but for nutrients
i'm hungry okay i did that too
my mom didn't cook very well so
sometimes you just left home alone
and just digging around the pantry and
you find like a couple mcdonald's
ketchup packets and like
all right for you it's it's you had a
taste desert
yeah you're like i was taste deprived i
mean
we were definitely like we didn't have a
lot of money but my mom always found a
way to make some type of good
food in some way you know what i'm
saying but i was also left home alone a
lot you know
so i remember i almost set the house on
fire one time
i used i thought i was such a [ __ ]
like chef like finessing recipes and
[ __ ]
like i would do [ __ ] like i would take
like hot dogs and slice them up
put them over crackers remember those
like chicken crackers
yeah chicken in a basket yeah yeah and
they're like chicken flavored crackers
they're so good it's like chicken
bouillon crackers
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i would take
that and like yeah chicken
imagine the chicken flavor top ramen
yeah like that chicken flavor top ramen
but on a cracker yes and it actually
smells like
ramen when i eat them now so i would say
i've never seen this so i would do that
and i would put them out yeah yeah
yeah yeah chicken in a basket it looks
like a spelled like
they're delicious i put cheetah on she's
like oh my god these are really good
they still fella yeah
so i would do that and i would like peel
string cheese and lace it over that and
then like throw it in the microwave and
i thought i was a [ __ ] chef you're
making like hors d'oeuvres
have you tried the veggie ones that
taste like v8 no
there's like veggie ones crackers yeah
okay but it's like
i've had those with herbs yeah it's like
it has like a tomato flavored
tomato and i don't know what you're
talking about what are they called i
don't know i don't know but my grandma
always got them though yeah those are
that's what you melt cheese on it oh
[ __ ]
that's old people food right there yeah
100
that's where i learned about it my gran
my mom makes spaghetti with grape jelly
what and i caught her doing it and i was
so disgusted and confused how does it
work
it's [ __ ] bomb but i didn't know that
she used grape jelly in it mix it then
one of the things that the end product
you can't tell
but it's just a little bit in the middle
of it it's somewhere in there
it happens and i i don't know it's
really good the thing that made my
grandma make look
appetizing like a [ __ ] with
cigarettes
in the middle of the day every time i
visit with my grandma in like taiwan
like after lunch she would always smoke
and i'm like why do you smoke
grandma and she's like oh this is how i
knock out and i would see her get like a
robe
and then put it on herself and she would
just smoke at the dinner table and then
there's this [ __ ]
this is before you knew second the
actual tablecloth
this is before you uh knew secondhand
smoke was bad so she just had like her
whole [ __ ] cloud like
around her inside the house and i'm just
like grandma that looks so tight
i mean that's what like why like that's
why people start smoking right because
that [ __ ] just looks cool
it does because i mean it's never like
you're never like getting high when you
think of cigarettes it's never like oh
i'm doing this
like a head change i mean that's what i
heard right but like i feel like when
you're young you do it just because you
see it in movies and [ __ ] it just
looks cool yeah the whole motion of it
like packing it like just like
oh you got a lighter and you like the
other person it's just like the whole
thing about it the [ __ ] image of just
someone chilling just like yeah talking
like when dave chappelle [ __ ] smokes
it looks so it makes me want to smoke
yeah
he does it like that or whatever it's
[ __ ] sick it's like he told me a
joint
yeah but he looks so relaxed it is a
joint isn't it
no it's cigarettes bro he [ __ ] smokes
cigarettes
but he smokes cigarettes like a like it
is a joint though because he
he does smoke weed like you'll know if
someone smokes weed by the way they hold
the cigarette
and how they flip it around and all that
because cigarette smokers will smoke it
a certain way
but if you if you know how if you if
you're used to holding a joint
you'll do this and then you'll flip it
around in your hand and like yeah
i never got into smoking but the
community aspect of it like the whole
like yo you want some was always so cool
and then like the weed yeah and then the
fact that everybody that i worked with
at the shitty high rise downtown
they all got extra breaks because they
were smokers that's what i [ __ ] hated
about it
cigarette everybody oh yeah that's what
i hate it's in the military right like
you're going through some [ __ ] hard
training and [ __ ]
and then you take zero breaks and then
if there's like five guys like oh should
we do a cigarette break
all of a sudden it's okay and so
everyone goes over there and then i'm
like hey can we do like a non-smoking
break and now everyone thinks i'm like
the fruitiest guy in the world
you could you could smoke in the um
military like
yeah yeah like in boot camp and it's an
okay thing like everyone's like oh let's
take a break real quick and everyone
the smokers go over there and they all
get to smoke and i'm like i can't call a
non uh what happens to the rest of the
people everyone still keeps going
you just sit there well you sit and i
guess you get a break too but it's not
something but you don't get to
go time out right but if you're smoking
a cigarette so even the higher ups
are okay with it yeah everyone looks
like a screaming in your face but the
moment you say smoke breaking no no no
no no no
this is like a smoke this is like um i
guess um
it's not boot camp it's not yeah it's
not boot camp and it's not in the middle
of training but like let's say
there's there's really no i guess off
time
and then except for that you get your
off time well for some people it's just
like how they
jump start their day and then some
people they up start their day
[Laughter]
nice because today's video is brought to
you by
upstart baby so there's a lot of
economic chatter right now about the
state of the market
is it recovering how long will it take
have we seen the worst
but if you're struggling to pay off high
interest credit card debt you can wait
you can't wait for those answers you
need to take action now with upstart
there's actually something you can do
today to help fight off high interest
credit card debt
upstart is the revolutionary online
lending platform that knows
you're more than just a credit score
unlike some of the other lenders upstart
can reward you
based on your job history in the form of
a smarter rate and it lets you skip
going to the bank who can be uh which
can be a pain in the ass because it's
completely online
they offer loans from 1 000 all the way
up to 50
dollars so you can consolidate your debt
into one
easy fixed rate payment upstart makes it
fast and simple to check your rate since
it's just a soft pull it won't affect
your credit score and the hard pull
happens if you accept your rate
and then proceed with your application
and the best part of it is
the loan is approved if the loan is
approved and accepted most people get
their funds the very next business day
which is crazy fast
yeah that's pretty fast see why upstart
has over six thousand five star reviews
on trustpilot and hurry to upstart.com
record to find out how low your upstart
rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
record your loan amount will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
not all applicants will qualify for the
full amount
thanks upstart thank you very much good
read guys
so tim how has the pregnancy been up
until this point
dude so she's just entered into the
final trimester
that's not the final there's technically
a fourth that yeah how long is the
trimester
three months um yeah three months she's
showing a lot now huh
she's showing a lot more um we actually
you know
they told us that our baby's like like
nothing to be concerned about but it's
like a small baby right now a word yeah
so i mean so i mean but i feel like it's
a tiny baby it's a i mean i'm a tiny
person
so is chia so it's like it's natural
we're gonna have a tiny baby
it'd be weird if they're like yo you got
a big ass baby in there for some reason
um did you gender reveal the baby no
we we're waiting and until the baby
comes out oh you're not even gonna know
no not gonna know do you know the old
wives tales you know like if the
the belly is shaped a certain way it's
like um that's what's accurate
is it i think so or if your mood's a
certain way like but that's what my mom
says
here's what i've also been hearing since
like chia's body hasn't been kind of
going through so much
during not nothing crazy but like did i
tell you guys she got chicken pox what
but she got chicken pox okay let me tell
you let me tell you uh
randomly one night what the [ __ ] she is
canadian she is canadian what does that
mean
chicken pox
she had chicken
she woke up she had this little thing on
her chest and i thought it was a spider
bite right
because it looked just like maybe like a
little weird like a big spider bite yeah
is that funny any bug that you can't
recognize the spider bite
it will it was it was intense bro i'm
like that's gonna be a [ __ ] just
weird it's gotta be a [ __ ] spider
because our house has huge spider suit
but anyways
and then she had like a little thing
here and i thought ah now you're
freaking out about the spider bites so
it's just making you break out in like
hives right like the stress yeah so she
got a little thing here a little thing
here and like a little thing on her neck
and we're like what the [ __ ] what could
this be
what's wrong with you yeah so we went to
go get it looked at and
someone was like they were like oh maybe
it's um shingles
because like you know but shingles is
supposed to be really painful and it
wasn't really painful just kind of itchy
at first
and then we thought uh someone said oh
it could be
uh like just a form of herpes that pops
up on your skin
all casual like that well they all just
form a heartbeat well cause since like
when you're pregnant
your hormones start going crazy so maybe
it was something that was dormant in her
and then the hormones started making it
pop off right
so doctor was like have you ever had
chickenpox she's like
yeah my mom said i had a chickenpox when
i was younger and uh we're like okay so
it's not chickenpox but they're like
we don't know what it is we're gonna run
some blood check it out
and um and i'm like well if if you got
the chicken pox
i'm gonna get the chicken boxes i've
also i've never had the chicken pot no
way
you didn't take the vaccine i didn't get
vaccinated you never
got chicken pox i didn't think i got
vaccinated right you're the luckiest
person i know well
how do you live through the 90s and not
have chickens i don't know well let me
tell you what happened
so we do her blood test and we go get
the results and the doctor's like
so we're shocked because it's 100
percent chickenpox wow
that that you had that was like on her
[ __ ] so it was dormant and then it came
back
no here's the thing so she called her
mom and her mom's like and i'm like
she's like
mom did i have the chicken box or not
and the mom's like i think you did
oh geez so then you know if you got
chicken pox though
so they ran the blood so they told us
the blood test said not only has she
never had chickenpox
but she was never like vaccinated either
and and so she had the [ __ ]
chickenpox right
isn't that dangerous while you're
pregnant well okay so let me tell you
right so that too
um so then so then we're confused as to
why i didn't get the chicken pox
because like we were next to each other
same bed like you eat chicken too and i
eat
so much chicken you should be itching
right now yeah right exactly
um so chickenpox sucks so i did a blood
test
never been vaccinated never had the
chickenpox so both of you guys got lied
to by your parents about your condition
with chickenpox no i knew i never had
the chicken
yes yeah but you thought you had been
back
vaccine doesn't work on chickenpox
everybody gets chickenpox right no
isaac's never gone no
they came out with a vaccine in the 90s
it's like extinctions
there's a bunch of kids out there that
don't know what it's like to have
chickenpox in elementary which is wrong
i know i think everyone should get it
what about you now can you catch it now
or do you get do you get the vaccine
because of that they were like well
maybe you should get vaccinated now
wait but how does she get it we have no
idea she again she doesn't go anywhere
yeah so
it was like a huge [ __ ] mystery it's
still a mystery yeah yeah yeah
you do not get it i don't know well my
dad thinks i'm
immune to all disease because i'm the
chosen one is what he tells me all the
time that's cute
so there's that what's her biggest
craving right now her biggest craving
uh randomly she'll just crave kind of
things that she
she grew up eating like a really
specific brand of like
instant noodles no no like you gotta get
some canadian products shipped over some
poutine she craved
um no no but the noodles she craved they
they have it out here it was the sapporo
the ichiban
yeah yeah yeah she loves that [ __ ] but i
brought all that up to say
something you guys asked me something i
asked you about how the pregnancy is
going and you said uh something yeah
rewind guys it was about the pregnancy i
think you were trying to show off that
you're their chosen one no no
what is the prophecy of the chosen one
dude oh i bought all that to say
it the baby's doing all this [ __ ] to her
body and the wives tale that i've been
hearing in the comments
is that they think it's a girl because
they say
if it's a girl she steals your beauty
and wreaks havoc on your body that is
the thing i mean
that's what it is i thought it was if
it's a dude then you get a mustache and
all kinds of weird
my mom said she had a mustache when she
had me well i don't know
i don't know i know some girls out there
where the mom's hotter and i'm like she
didn't steal your beauty at all
oh that had daughters
but yeah so they say it can be dangerous
for the baby if you get chickenpox
during the pregnancy but we luckily
hit it right at a stage where it it it
didn't
negatively affect the baby but we also
got some tests to see because it can
kind of
affect the baby and some like it could
have affected like sight and a bunch of
yeah all that chicken pox talk man i got
itchy bro
my body got so itchy what is the chosen
one what happens to you
are you gonna kill vampires like what's
going on um yeah he always just says
like i'm supposed to like just um
uh uh make it big like uh represent for
all the asian people like you know like
uh bring them to the promised land and
[ __ ]
hell yeah damn well there's no more new
land to discover
so yeah i i hope it's not the moon or
something the metaphorical promise maybe
it's like dubai and they make
it like oh yeah how do they how does he
know that does he like
he could read your future maybe he said
yeah maybe he
maybe that's the reason i'm so like uh i
think so highly of myself you know what
i'm saying
he's just gassing me up yeah has always
been ingraining that in your head well i
might have incepted him maybe i just
started telling him that as a young ass
[Music]
kid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you